you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
and I'm gonna play a live blitz game
this is a 3-2 time control so let's see
what we get here
okay I was wondering if he was on the
move okay let's try a Sicilian
definitely a bit out of my comfort zone
let's see what we got
just myth more a gambit okay let's go
with the e6 so I like having the
increment I'm sure I'll be playing off
of it so that's at least a nice way to
avoid opponents who try to burn time
towards the end those tight and time
burning strategies not so good with
increments so I'm just prepping a nice
secure home here for the Queen on c7
alright let's get my night out
'if I've is met with Queen eight five so
night out d6 they have a grip over they
have a grip over d5 how to play this mmm
Queen c7 Queen c7 and still retains some
options for my bishop for a moment yeah
I'm gonna get on with going for this
structure on the head for a hedgehog
small pond center I don't see any reason
not to just play this right away so I
can be really quick to get my bishop on
this diagonal sometimes there could be a
quick Bishop f3 or a combination of f4
and Bishop f3 so let's get him here put
my knight connect my Knights Bishop to
e7 so that's a bit of a surprising move
I'm gonna go here first maybe in some
cases my knight might want to go to c6
so I'll leave this option open for the
moment and I'll still keep the option
open I'm wondering this is what it was
what there was the more aggressive move
f4 but white is still gonna have a some
pull here computer I'll be having an
advantage for white due to space hmm
you know I guess at the end of the day
I'm still gonna go here
one thing you have to be aware of is the
night is on c6 and you play Queen c7
there's Knight d5 ideas and I'm captured
upon recaptures and then you're in a pin
so okay
definitely very aggressive here is white
this week and c4 so my rook isn't doing
anything in the corner I should commit
him
Queen Queen c7 Queen b8 I really haven't
been thinking up into this point so far
these have just been pretty natural
moves minor pieces out half opened file
I have something to bite out an
additional pressure is right around the
corner with 95 I'm expecting maybe
Knight to b3 at some point to get in
this advance although I have a lot of
pieces on it okay well let's see you
know what after after I played Bishop d7
I was forgetting that I was on e4 twice
so that's the reason why the F 3 was
played to reinforce that e pawn I'm
actually ahead on time okay that's good
news so oh let me insert this if they're
gonna if they're gonna really want to
play g5 let them commit another pawn
weak in their Kings side a little bit
more and maybe only then will I think
about what to do with my knight so on h4
I wonder if I should go 95 probably h4
weakens g3 and g4 with this one move so
on h4 95 g5 takes takes and then I could
move my knight we're at h5 into g3 is an
idea or maybe dropping back to d7
although I should be looking more at the
forward moves first
ooh you're really setting up some
sacrifice over here that might be the
case definitely don't want to push my
pawn here that's terrible for too many
reasons Knight f5 Knight d5 so naive 5
is when I'm thinking what I really want
to babysit this h6 pawn hmm what about
rook to e8 in case sacrifices my bishop
could come over here to defend a little
bit
oh yeah I'm gonna shoot for that I'd
really like to have my bishop around
near my King as a defense if there is in
fact a sacrifice over here okay so we're
in the world where they maneuvering what
squares have they given up with that
last move they given up d5 so I should
probably push and get this break in
she's no longer than her to control it
and there's no reply with the e5 I think
now is the time to act in the center
opening up the position my opponent went
in Reverse let's open the position up
where I have well how well plays can a
knight be on d1 so just general
considerations here prompting these
specific moves so on any pawn capture
I'm just recapturing or in fact after C
takes maybe I inconvenience the Queen
ever-so-slightly
that's a bizarre move because I'm
winning upon here
am I not what's the story with that I'm
on this pawn three times take that guy
so at the end he's gonna end up ooh okay
so that is interesting so this was an
anticipated well this was the idea
apparently okay
wow I'm thinking of still uh
breaking this pawn duo up he five pawn
takes Knight takes let's go for it I
know I'm giving up this square but I'm
gonna see I'm gonna roll the dice with
this one getting pretty crazy
now pawn takes I know I'm inviting a
piece into this square soon let me take
here I want to have this square
available dropping the bishop back in
the knight here is my idea let's do that
in fact they have a ton of pieces on
this square but after a bunch of
captures here I have Knight h7 and then
Queen g5 stuff my queen doesn't have any
squares that's a scary sight I have this
pawn push of 20 seconds left 14 white
rook fd1 what would I do on that
okay forget about it they're not going
there they're in a pin hmm tricky tricky
tricky this move and some sacrifice here
maybe I should just push yeah I get that
e4 square open there's no tricks over
here are there I'm pretty well
coordinated so this was my idea
jump in here get centralized recapture
with my rook seems like the more active
but Noah Bishop f3 20 seconds off we are
living off of the increment here so I
should probably get out of the pinned
yeah let's do that
a lot of pieces here I'm hitting b4 but
I have to keep pressure I have to defend
my knight wow I feel like going for a
queen sac all right we'll try it okay
we're gonna give it a go here yeah and
that's a blunder they're gonna pin there
or is it cannot even guess any of this
guy's moves
let's take here I'm on the bishop
they're gonna do sacrifice here I need
to get coordinated I think I'm
coordinated now on this pawn twice
alright I still have to stay coordinated
here hmm and have to move faster my
goodness
two seconds I have coordination now I'm
gonna take that pawn next I was going to
okay I have good coordination bang some
time here in the line of fire there with
I could go into a self pin and just
defend everything and pawn push then
let's get out of this first
and now push I could take here with a
check I'm not afraid of that am i checks
here on g8 I could run around not
getting mated okay 15 seconds
let's get some checks in this should be
too bad to play keep my rooks connected
in fact I could do a king walk over here
to b4 keep that pawn and a pin my bishop
is super gluing everything together
King walk up here just avoid the main
ones I'm gonna hunt down that pawn um
I'll weasel over here and in fact I'm
threatening mate
so that's nice to go here creeping over
just to put pressure over here and yeah
alright now I scoop this pawn up now
they have to be careful I should have
been actually shooting for this move
much sooner suppose their king f5 soon
just have to watch out for checks I
think I have all checks covered let's
throw in some checks they have but
they're forced back now let's try this
okay maybe I could start now let's let's
guard this square here from any Queen
checks and I can move up should I start
inching my pawn a little bit you know
why not 20 seconds just watch out for
Forks here I'm getting a little bit of
time a little bit more maybe give a
check can I pick that pawn up and not
have any worry of checks against my king
yeah I'm still really well coordinated
here do that
it's another king is cut off
Bishop back here maybe even March my
pond there must have been something
cleaner let's drop back and dodge some
checks soon in fact let's give it a
check here hmm
let's give a check they're just staying
coordinated where's the maid I'm sure
I've missed a bunch okay now that's
finally running into a discovery move
the computer is going to know stalemate
after I have this capture now computers
going to have a lot to say about this
one a lot of ways to improve and this
should be GG next okay they resigned all
right I'm gonna pop this into stockfish
and see what it has to say about it okay
let's see what stockfish has to say
about this game here so where was where
were the critical points in the game so
far pretty standard stuff I don't think
anything has been missed around here
just questioning a little bit of the
move order here with b6 and Bishop to b7
this actually might be a bit of an
inaccuracy the computer points out
nothing significant for white I don't
think at least something about close to
0.5 likes Bishop to f3 getting on the
diagonal right away and it suggests a 5
not a move I would really want to play
but I don't know how bad it would be
I could watch over the d5 square with
Bishop to e6 I don't know how well place
the bishop would be on that square okay
yeah something to certainly be aware of
a quick deployment of a queen or a
bishop in this case on the light
diagonal the main diagonal but okay the
usual Plus here for white around point 4
you don't see the evaluation you'll just
have to trust me that that's what it's
saying it didn't like g4 probably could
have guessed that but yeah g4 what is it
liking its liking a3 here's a move
yeah Ponta a three or even Queen to d2
is an idea okay this throws the
advantage away it says dead even the
likes h6 and Queen D 295 as a follow-up
that's what I was going to go for about
anything wrong with rook to e8 no this
was something I was concerning yeah this
has it as minus two here within Bishop
coming back here to defend Queen check
Bishop g7 this is a master defender the
King side so I guess this still wouldn't
be here if I went instead with 9595
let's see takes takes it still has it as
minus two here for black with Knight FG
for is a follow up Wow
and on pawn takes Knight Bishop g5 Wow
okay that's it's getting pretty wild
although no I can you know I can see
there's a lot of control here over the
dark squares as a check can be inserting
on e3 maybe even prior to picking the
rook up on c1 just to kick the King on a
light square place that pawn in a pin
hmm okay that's interesting I just went
with something solid rook to e8 and it
does like d5 so okay that's nice and I
guess it didn't really like this idea of
a pawn sacrifice instead of Knight - f -
it goes in four takes takes and the
Knight f5 with them Bishop to f8 you
know it still has it as an advantage for
black about - point nine something
something in that ballpark so this was
the right idea to take action in the
center and reply to your opponent
running in Reverse this is a much
different story if white can rely upon
well if I can say to themselves yeah the
position is going to remain closed
although I don't know that you would
relate to in a fine this is close
there's not a locked pawn structure but
if you're going in reverse and your
opponent is able to them react and open
the
not certainly brings a move like that
into question
d5 takes takes it stills it's gonna like
black for a little bit I think around
here it still has it as an upon
advantage for black anything wrong with
captures no 85 is being called out here
nothing wrong with Bishop Tao f8 still
about upon advantage it does like this
move here or now it's even with some
time to think it does pointing out III
is a move and also a5 so I drop back
clean c3 and now oh man - 3 I totally
missed this move I spent some time - on
this position deny this is fine as well
it's a plus I should say a minus -
advantage with e3 but even better is
Knight d5 taking advantage of the pin
and on Queen g3 we're picking up the
dark square bishop and then wow just
scooping up another pun and this is
giving up everything
c5 square it's not just a pond but it's
weakening C the C pawn granting the C 5
square for pieces and the dark squares
are just completely killed of course the
night picking up the dark square bishop
you know I I was focused on this move
here taking advantage of this pawn
maybe I should have looked more into the
two squares that this pawn really no
longer controls with regard to captures
okay III isn't losing anything
this is losing something there's a shift
here it likes a5 in this position Knight
e4 throws away the advantage it's only
about mmm a half pawn advantage for
black now yeah what was anything other
than a five here no another move is g5
iMovie just don't play that's weakening
there's no way I'm playing g5 in this
position but okay 94 takes bishop takes
I was going to do this but Bishop to f3
there's some trouble here still has it
as even I am on this bishop
- yeah it's still about an even position
but Bishop takes rook there there's
anything missed rook d6 I have a feeling
it's not gonna like my sacrifice here of
the Queen
yeah it doesn't like it it's objectively
bad yeah I thought I would have
coordination what was better instead of
that Oh dropping the bishop all the way
back maybe lining up a battery on this
diagonal although there is still Bishop
f3 although no Queen efore is hitting
the bishop and threatening stuff against
the White King okay well I went with
this sack it has it now as a Danish for
white by about a pond and changeup on
and a half
starting with Queen to d2 what was
played Knight there yeah so that was a
blunder so we had back-to-back big shift
right around this moment here of course
we were living it off of the increment
takes takes yeah Queen to d2 this is not
a sound sacrifice but fortunately I
didn't find this Queen to d2 move maybe
there were even others aside from Queen
to d2 just checking right now yeah that
seems to be the best yeah maybe there's
a half pond advantage with here
the c5 advance but best would be Queen
to d2 at this stage after Knight there
yeah that's throwing away stuff of
course +3 advantage it still is about a
+3 now it's -5 likes rook to C 8 minus 7
you know I don't think I lost anything
around here because I stayed coordinated
and this went on for what another 40
moves I'm just gonna skip through this
I'm sure I missed a lot of stuff I'm
just looking for any mates that I might
have missed everything is reading as
minus 5 I just popped up real quick on -
49 so something close to going back here
for a little bit so
that close to me when it's saying -49
but everything is just glued together
starting with the bishop the rooks are
coordinated so the only thing you have
to watch out for is the coordination of
the Queen in one of these pawns or the
king like making one threats in some
weird cases but just think coordinated
and that was the name of the game there
and it just blinked there for a moment
about triple zeros with king g5 oh no
that's just something with the computer
it sees a little bit of a pattern it
starts to recognize that it's heading
towards a repetition but it was never a
drop no perpetual in this ending and now
it has it as mating 14 mating five right
here yeah let's just look at one of them
where was the main five right here now
mating six at this point here starting
with rook to see for Roxy four and on
Queen check excuse me Oh Oh instead of
going after the Queen in this final
position ah I see okay well that was
simplest to just go after the Queen but
Brooke c4 king g3 rook takes c1 pretty
much what happened in the game by that
point it might as well go after the
Queen and not have to calculate a mate
but uh okay interesting game definitely
looking forward to the d5 pawn break in
this open Sicilian
and it really just grabbed my attention
of course whenever well as soon as my
opponent went into reverse here it's all
the more appealing to they'll strike
straight in for that d5 break and it
opened up to my benefit but at the end
of the day that I the ensuing idea of a
queen sacrifice was not sound Queen to
d2 as a reply would have had a pawn and
a half advantage there for white but uh
didn't play through with it but anyhow
feel free to leave any comments in the
comment section below to this video and
I'll catch you in the next one
take care
you